estamos en el problema 48 dice si x al
cuadrado es sumado a x la suma es 42
cuál de los siguientes podría ser un
valor de x entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es plantear primero la ecuación
que nos están diciendo tratar de
resolverla y ver con cuál de estos
valores coincide digo también podríamos
tratar de sustituir cada uno de estos
valores para lo que nos dice el texto
pero vamos a hacer esto un poco más
interesante así que si tenemos que x al
cuadrado es sumado a x entonces vamos a
tener x al cuadrado le sumamos x esto
debe ser igual a 42 y ya tenemos una
ecuación planteada pero vamos a llevarlo
a la forma que siempre nos gusta tener
es decir una forma cuadrática igualada a
cero entonces podemos restar 42 de ambos
lados y tenemos x cuadrada más x menos
42 debe ser igual a 0 y ahora si ya
tenemos la forma que nos gusta para
resolver entonces una forma de
resolverlo que creo que va a ser más
qué buena es tratar de factorizar el
lado izquierdo entonces tengo que buscar
dos números que multiplicados me den
menos 42 y sumados me den 1 verdad aquí
hay un 1 como coeficiente de la equis
entonces tenemos que buscar los factores
de 42 puede ser 2 por 21 pero bueno ahí
no nos va a ser que la suma nos dé 1 y
de hecho tenemos que ver que como aquí
hay un menos tenemos que multiplicar dos
números y para que nos dé algo negativo
uno debe ser positivo y uno negativo ok
y de hecho el positivo tiene que ser más
grande para que al sumarlos me dé aquí
positivo' verdad por ejemplo en este
caso a mí me parece que 7 y menos 6
funciona y 7 x menos 6 es menos 42 y 7
menos 6 es 1 entonces funciona muy bien
tenemos x 7 que multiplica a x menos 6
ok entonces 7 6 por 7 42 y como aquí hay
un signo menos aquí va con menos y luego
7 si le sumamos menos 6
a uno entonces esta factorización fue
buena y la igualamos a cero y aquí viene
el truco porque si tenemos un producto
de dos números que nos da cero entonces
alguno de ellos tiene que ser cero
entonces puede ser que x 70 o bien x 6
es igual a cero si x + 7 es igual a 0 x
es igual a menos 7 y si x 6 es igual a 0
entonces sumamos 6 de ambos lados y nos
queda x igual a 6 estas son mis dos
respuestas vemos que coincide una de
ellas con la respuesta a vámonos con el
problema 49 qué cantidad se debe agregar
en ambos lados de esta ecuación para
completar el cuadrado ok entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer es agregar algo de
este lado y del otro lado también para
que se preserven la igualdad pero de tal
suerte que del lado izquierdo yo pueda
esto factorizar lo como como un binomio
al cuadrado entonces recordemos que es
un binomio al cuadrado x más un número
al cuadrado es
x cuadrada más
bueno vamos a desarrollarlo tenemos x +
a que es multiplicado por sí mismo otra
vez y esto si lo desarrollamos es x x x
x cuadrada x x a es a x a x x es otra
equis y ahora es cuadrada muy bien
entonces esto lo podemos agrupar y me
queda x cuadrada cuántos x tuve pues
tuve 2 x más a cuadrada entonces si lo
comparamos con esto de acá arriba
nosotros tenemos que sumar la cuadrada
para lo cual necesitamos saber quién es
a entonces para conocer a tenemos que
identificar este menos 8 este menos 8
con el 2
entonces si dos veces este número es
menos 8 quiere decir que este número es
la mitad de menos 8 y la mitad de menos
8 es menos 4 así que lo que tenemos que
agregar de ambos lados es menos 4 al
cuadrado como está determinado aquí
entonces lo que vamos a tener es x
cuadrada menos 8 x dejamos un espacio y
debe ser y esto igual a 5 entonces qué
es lo que sumamos a cuadrada pero a
dijimos que era menos 4 y menos 4 al
cuadrado es 16 entonces sumamos de ambos
lados 16 y lo que me queda es lo
siguiente x cuadrada menos 8 x más 16 es
x + a que nuestro caso es menos 4
entonces tenemos x menos 4 no quería
decir a quise decir menos 4 al cuadrado
esto debe ser igual a 16 más cinco que
son 21 entonces que fue cuál es la
respuesta que fue lo que tuvimos que
agregar en ambos lados pues agregamos 16
y esa sería la respuesta de uno podría
por ejemplo tratar de resolver esto saca
raíz cuadrada y resolver la equis pero
ya no está en lo que nos pide el
problema así que vamos a saltarnos al
siguiente problema
me dice cuáles son las soluciones de la
ecuación cuadrática x cuadrada más 6 x
igual a 16 entonces qué es lo que
hacemos como siempre tenemos que pasarlo
a mi forma que que nos agrada para
resolver esto es una cuadrática igual a
cero entonces si restamos 16 de ambos
lados nos queda x cuadrada más 6 x menos
16 igual a 0 y otra buena opción creo yo
que podemos hacer es factorizar la
expresión de la izquierda entonces
buscamos dos números que multiplicados
me den menos 16 y sumado 6 entonces otra
vez como lo que hay que multiplicar me
queda con signo negativo lo que tenemos
que tener es lo que hay que tener más
bien es uno positivo y uno negativo y
además como la suma es positiva pues el
más grande debe tener el signo positivo
entonces uno podría por ejemplo intentar
con 4 y 4 4 x menos 4 es menos 16 pero 4
más menos 4 es 0 entonces ese no
funciona x
8 y 28 y 2 su producto es menos 16 y su
suma 8 + menos 26 entonces funciona de
maravilla funciona de maravilla y
entonces escribimos que esto es x + 8
por x menos 2 igual a cero entonces
nuevamente un producto que me da cero
quiere decir que algunos de los factores
es cero
entonces x + 8 es cero o bien x menos
dos es cero si esto pasa restamos ocho
de ambos lados y tenemos x igual a menos
8 y si esto pasa sumamos 2 de ambos
lados y me queda x es igual a 2
entonces las respuestas son 2 y menos 8
que se encuentran en la opción
vamos muy bien ahora vamos con el
siguiente problema que dice el 51
lourdes resolvió correctamente la
ecuación x cuadrada más 4 x igual a 6
completando el cuadrado entonces hay que
completar el cuadrado que ecuación es
parte de su solución ok entonces hay que
identificar alguna de estas ecuaciones
que de hecho aquí deben llevar cuadrados
aquí deben llevar cuadrados muy bien
y ver cuál de estas opciones corresponde
a la solución que pudo haber dado
lourdes así que copiamos esto que
tenemos acá y tenemos x cuadrada más 4x
que le sumamos algo va a ser igual a 6 y
le vamos a tener que sumar de ambos
lados lo mismo y otra vez
necesitamos encontrar el número que al
elevarlo al cuadrado bueno tenemos que
encontrar un número aquí que al sumarlo
nos da un binomio al cuadrado
desarrollado verdad entonces esto ya lo
vimos acá arriba en el ejercicio
anterior y se calcula dividiendo a la
mitad este número que tenemos aquí el 4
si lo dividimos entre 2 nos queda 2 y
eso al elevarlo al cuadrado es lo que
hay que sumar aquí entonces nos da 2 al
cuadrado es 4 y si sumamos 4 de ambos
lados lo que obtenemos es x más 2 verdad
que fue el número que encontramos es la
raíz cuadrada de este o la mitad de éste
y es x + 2 al cuadrado debe ser igual a
6 + 4 que es 10 y eso es nuestra opción
b en la opción b entonces todo el
detalle está en que podamos que dividir
esto a la mitad y elevarlo al cuadrado
eso es lo que sumamos verdad y además el
número que queda aquí es la mitad de
este justo justo lo que tuvimos que
elevar al cuadrado para sumar de ambos
lados espero no sea muy confuso y creo
que hay tiempo para uno más dice alfredo
está resolviendo esta ecuación factor
izando entonces qué expresión sería uno
de sus factores a mí se me ocurre viendo
esta ecuación que todos los coeficientes
tienen son múltiplos de 5 entonces
podemos primero dividir entre 5 y que
nos queda 10 entre 5 son 2 x cuadrada
menos 25 entre 5 son 5 x 15 entre 5 son
3 y esto me da igual a cero ok entonces
aquí el problema es que tenemos un 2
acompañando al x cuadrada entonces pues
verás que realmente es complicado pero
podríamos plantear una posible solución
digamos que tal que esto se factorizar
de la forma 2 x + a por x + b ok
ya lo mejor tú dirás bueno y como se te
ocurrió plantearlo de esta forma y
simplemente es de ver que aquí hay un 2x
cuadrada entonces es como 2x por equis
verdad
entonces bueno esta es mi propuesta y
hay que encontrar quién sería y quién
sería b entonces hay que desarrollar
esto 2x x x es 2 x cuadrada 2 x x b son
2 b x a x x es x ya por b simplemente es
a b muy bien entonces si agrupamos los
estos términos estos términos tenemos 2x
cuadrada más que es lo que multiplica x
pues sería 2 b más a que multiplica a x
más up urbe entonces fíjense que ahora
tenemos que encontrar dos números que
multiplicados me den 3 y que el doble
del primero más el segundo me dé menos 5
esto esto es bastante más complicado que
lo que ya habíamos tenido antes sin
embargo no puede ser muy difícil los
factores de 3 son lo hay hay poquitos
verdad es un número primo sólo tiene dos
factores y es 1 y 3 así que por ejemplo
si ponemos menos que será que el
producto debe ser de dos números con el
mismo signo entonces y además la suma
está debe ser un número negativo así que
es menos 1 por menos 3 verdad ahora cuál
sería b y cuál sería por ejemplo si a es
menos tres veces menos uno tenemos menos
dos menos tres en menos 5 funciona
funciona muy bien y entonces esto al
final me queda 2x menos 3 que multiplica
a x menos 1 verdad el doble de b que es
éste es menos 2 y si le sumo a que es
menos 3 es menos 5 y el producto de
menos 1 con menos tres es 3 y esto debe
ser bueno esto es igual a 0 pero sólo
nos preguntan cuál sería uno de los
factores y aquí justamente uno de los
factores es 2x menos 3 que coincide con
nuestra respuesta de entonces
de hecho de hecho
bueno con esto basta aquí dijimos que b
es igual a menos 1 y que es igual a
menos 3
en realidad resolver este tipo de
ecuaciones ya resulta como todo un arte
verdad no hay una no hay algo mecánico o
algo que una un método que uno sigue
constantemente y que nos diga cómo
resolver el problema si no se requiere
de mucha inteligencia de mucha habilidad
pero sobre todo de que agarre estén
sucias las manos y hagas muchos
ejercicios para resolver esto entonces
ya se me acabó el tiempo nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo